we want to celebrate a remarkable woman
together
and share the story of erica gamble also
known as
the wig doctor from marietta georgia
just take a look
hair means confidence hair means
power hair means character if i
can provide people a hair loss solution
then i know that i'm doing what i'm
called to do
i am dr erica gamble but everyone knows
me as the wig doctor
the wig doctor opened in june of 2015
in marietta georgia to service people
who
are going through chemotherapy
treatments
autoimmune disorders or life changes
ninety percent of the people who walk
through this door
have never worn a wig and they have no
idea
what a wig entails my clients
become almost like family i had a
situation where i had
a little girl she was still in school
and she lost all of her hair
after seeing a family go through
something such as that
was really one of the main reasons why
i continue to do what i do there are
times when my clients come through these
doors
and they often feel wounded it is my
responsibility
to make them feel like warriors when
they leave
the struggles of small business are for
me
being a one-person show i do it all
marketing is difficult
because i often feel that i don't have
the tools
or the resources to reach the people
that i might be
missing in the market i started this
business
using my own resources buying what i
thought would be necessary i spent a lot
of my own
money to support my clients to make sure
that they have
everything that they need from me
[Music]
i'm here with gabrielle union fellow
beauty business owner
and entrepreneur and joining us is dr
erica gamble
popularly known as the wig doctor
hi erica
i watched your video and i
was just overwhelmed with your story
and what an amazing person you are
and over the course of obviously the
last
eight months and how it's impacted
everyone i know how much
the coronavirus has impacted small
businesses will you
speak about that because i know you put
so much of your own money into this
yeah finances have been really hard
during this time
you know honestly the doors aren't you
know they're not opening as much as they
did
prior to covet and so you know one thing
for certain is that
even though covet is happening and we're
in a pandemic cancer
diagnosis don't stop um hair loss
issues don't stop autoimmune diseases
don't stop and so
i still have people who are calling me
saying hey you know
i need help i am not saying no to anyone
that calls or anybody who you know walks
through the door
because the people in this community
really do need me
um and it's it's just been a challenge
and gabrielle when you were speaking
about
going through ivf and having a change in
your hair and a lot of women
when they have babies also their hair
changes or if they're going
through something like chemotherapy and
all of the
deep important difficult things to
discuss
such as you live your life by erica
i mean hair loss is a tremendous
psychological thing for for
really women and men but can you guys
speak to that
there's so much shame involved
for so many women um and certainly women
of color and
specifically black women our hair is our
crown
and when there's when your crown has
been knocked off your head
you feel less than you feel uh
self-conscious you feel like you you
lack
the confidence but i know when i was
experiencing
you know bald patches i only wore wigs
if i didn't have a wig i i you would
have never seen me i wouldn't have been
able to shoot my show
and and that's not life and death and
what erica is talking about and what
she's dealing with and what her
customers are dealing with
this is life and death and and how do
you move through the world as you're
battling for your life
a great wig can change your life child
it can change a life
um and so you are doing the lord's work
and and
i cannot say enough and when you lean
into service of uh you know for others
um the the word comes
in leaps and bounds and and it comes in
spades and so i
my advice would be to continue to lead
into service because
uh blessings god karma whatever you want
to say
it comes back to you and you you will
reap everything that you are sowing and
because you're such a beautiful
beautiful woman doing such amazing work
um this will come back to you
in ways that you you can't even begin to
imagine and i just want to thank you
as someone who has relied on wigs and in
my darkest hour i just want to thank you
and so many
others in the community who desperately
need you so please hold on help
is coming and erica use us as a
billboard right now
yes i would love to use you as a
billboard i mean i think it would be
amazing and that's where i need help
honestly
at the end of the day no matter how
often i think about giving up and
quitting which is literally really every
day
don't you dare okay we want to
contribute what you are doing is so
vital and important to empowerment you
are as gabrielle said doing
life or death business you are changing
people's
psyche and the confidence that they have
so we at flower beauty actually
we're launching hair tools on september
30th and we're going to send you
a ton of stuff we want to help style our
clients
i want to shine a big light on flawless
i think gabrielle
what you are doing is so crucial and
important again
to that confidence and how you live your
life
and i just have such deep respect for
what you're doing
and also i do know an amazing social
media guru
who i'd love to help give you some tips
and get you started on the right path
and will help along the way
and gabrielle and i want to help support
you and your efforts so together with
flower hair tools we're gifting you
this ten thousand dollar check just to
get you started thank you
and erica we're gonna make you um our
wcw for this wednesday to coincide with
the episode
so we'll we'll make sure to blow it up
as much as possible on my personal page
and on the flawless pages
thank you oh my gosh i just don't know
what this really really means
i i'm just like floored thank you
thank you both for being here dr erica
gamble the wig doctor and gabrielle
union grab a bitsy snack
and watch her in la's finest thank you
so much you guys